من يومين مشاهدينا والحزن والاسى مسيطرين
حول اسم الفنان الكبير جورج وسوف اللي
توفى ابنه وديع في بيروت بسبب نزيف في
المعده على اثر مضاعفات عمليه جراحيه كان
اجراها لتكميم المعده وتم الكشف عن تعرضه
لمضاعفات من بعد العمليه وثلاثه ازمات
قلبيه للاسف كان اخرها يوم الجمعه اللي
فشل الاطباء من بعدها بانعاشو وتم الاعلان
عن وفاته بعدها من دقائق بس تم دفن نجل
سلطان الطرب في مسقط راسه في الكفرون
بمحافظه طرطوس في سوريا وكان في استقباله
اهالي القريه اللي من وقت الاعلان عن
الخبر امتلات شوارعها بصور الراحل وتم
تشيعه من كنيسه مار الياس ووريا جثمانه
الثرى في مقبره العائله
مصارعه مصارعه الاخيره
ما بدي اسمع
صوتكم يا شباب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قبل الوداع الاخير الراحل وديع جورج وسوف
كان تمت مراسم تشييع في كنيسه القديس
نيكولا اولا في الاشرفيه في بيروت واللي
تم تداول الكثير من الفيديوهات منها
للحظات وصول جثمان الراحل ولقطات القاسيه
جدا بالنسبه لعائلته
الوداع
الحب نظاره
والقلب اه اه حس الضياع ومن وداع
قلبي الوداع
[موسيقى]
فليت بكير يا اخي
كسرتنا وكسرت قلبي بيك وكسرت قلوبنا كلنا
بيك كان اغلى شيء عندك بالدنيا كان همك بس
يضل مرتاح انت عايش كل حياتك كرماله
لتشوفه مبسوطه مرتاح
كلنا بهالعائله لنا حصه باسم وديع باي ابو
وديع امي ام وديع انا قلت امي
كل اللي بيعرف بيعرف قد ايه قلبه طيب
بيعرف قد ايه خدوم قد ايه بيحب العالم ما
بيطلب طلب اللي يقول له غيره بفكر بغيره
وما بيفكر بحاله صاحبه صاحبه نحب بيحب
الكل وبيساعد الكل
مشاهد قصيره جدا
الكبير جورج وسوف الله يرحمه طبعا ويعطيهم
الصبر والسلوان على كل حال مشاهدينا
الفنان جورج وسوف وعائلته من امبارح كانوا
بداوا في استقبال المعزين بالاشرفيه في
بيروت وتوافد الكثير من النجوم والفنانين
لتقديم العزاء وامتلات بالصور والفيديوهات
وصول الفنانين واللحظات المؤثره بينهم وما
بين سلطان الطرب جورج وسوف
خلاص
[موسيقى]
طول عمرك
الله يحفظك
[موسيقى]
هوايده مشاهدينا من بين الفيديوهات اللي
تم تداولها بشكل كبير فيديو مؤثر جدا
الحمد لله
وفاته جاءت بعد عمليه تكميم معده زي ما
كنا ذكرنا في احدى مستشفيات بيروت وصار
معه مضاعفات من بعدها ونزيف في المعده
تعرض لثلاث ازمات قلبيه متتاليه كان اخرها
يوم الجمعه اللي عجوز الاطباء عن انعاشوا
وللاسفه
واكدت محاميه العائله انه ما في اي نيله
التي اخذ اجراءات قانونيه ضد الطبيب وانه
ابدا ما تم الحديث عن الاخطاء الطبيه وانه
العائله بتعتبر هذا الوقت للحزن فقط
[موسيقى]